so a lot of people think that hustle
means breaking the rules i don't really
think that's what it means to me hustle
means finding out what the goal is what
the rules are
and kind of saying screw the rules
what's the best way that we can get
there
using the resources that we have
including our creativity that doesn't
mean half-assing things or to be sneaky
or to be scammy
but it means to how can we get from a to
b in an ethical way that makes everyone
really happy
yet we're going to think outside the box
and only use what we have
that's what hustling means to me
hustling is following your passions
pursuing what you believe in and getting
other people as excited as you are
about what you're working on hustling to
me is running straight into a brick wall
pausing to freak out but then stepping
back
diagnosing what's wrong fixing that and
moving on to the next brick wall for me
hustling means finding out the rules of
the game that you're playing
and how to break them to put things into
your favor hustling to me is doing
whatever
it takes to grow to reach the next order
of magnitude
hustling to me means finding something
you really are passionate about
and pursuing it without ever being
self-conscious about it
hustling means to me is selling other
people on
your dream and your vision and making
them buy into it to me hustling starts
with believing that you can
from there it's doing whatever it takes
to make that true sometimes
that's doing something particularly
clever and sometimes it's just brutal
hard work
hustle is really just about endurance
hustling is the ability to stretch the
dollar as far as it can go
hustling is well what i did to raise
money for my first company
i had no funding i couldn't get any
funding but i did have a lot of clothes
from j.crew
so i looked at the back of the j crew
catalog and they said there's unlimited
return policy
so i boxed everything up i shipped it
back to them and they sent me about two
thousand dollars that was what i started
my business with
hustling is something anyone can do you
just have to be a little bit crazy
to me hustling it's pretty simple just
means
never giving up hustling is being able
to stay true to yourself
and believing in you when tons of haters
are out there telling you otherwise and
being able to wake up every single
morning
not taking no for an answer that's
awesome to me
i guess hustling comes down to
resilience
to me hustling is all about being
relentless
you